like to talk about four common mistakes
that people make when they consume lemon
water I've done lots of videos on lemon
limes lemon water and the benefits but I
really haven't talked about the mistakes
that people make but the main benefit of
lemon juice is what it can do for kidney
stones in preventing kidney stones but
the citrates interfere with the
formation of a kidney stone okay and I'm
talking about the calcium oxalates
and I've done a video recently on that
being related to a deficiency in citrate
and so one way to get more citrates is
to consume more lemon juice another
benefit of lemon water or just lemon
juice is for its vitamin C but just
remember if you have pasteurized lemon
juice the heat kills off the vitamin C
now they probably add some vitamin C in
the form of ascorbic acid which is not
the four complex so if you really want
to get the benefits of vitamin C from
lemon juice or limes
just take a lemon or a lime and then
just squeeze it in water or blend the
whole thing in a blender and you can
actually drink that down and that works
really good if you add a little bit of a
like maybe electrolyte powder which has
a little bit of stevia in there so it
makes it a nice drink plus you have this
Spike of electrolytes but if it's
pasteurized chances are it's not going
to have a lot of vitamin C but one of
the common symptoms of vitamin C is
bleeding gums so if you're brushing your
teeth and you have this little pink
toothbrush suspected vitamin C
deficiency another symptom would be
fatigue another effect from lemon juice
is its antihistamine effect that's why
it's good for allergies histamines are
those things that your body makes in
reaction to an allergy that causes some
of the mucus and makes you tired there
to some degree kind of like a fatigue
poison another effect a lemon juice has
is its anti-fungal properties so it's
really good for candida fungus and
bacterial infections as well so you can
use it with other things as like a
natural
antibiotic another thing that lemon
juice will do it will help prevent the
formation of uric acid so it's good in
gout some types of gout is called
pseudogout which is really oxalates
right going into the big toe it's not
really uric acid and so citrates are
really good to counter the effects of
that effect and then also lemon juice
can help increase the absorption of iron
as well in the body all right so let's
just dive right into the mistakes
one is that you don't want to consume
this lemon water right before you eat
why because even though citric acid is
an acid
when it goes into the body
it gets burned up and it turns into an
alkaline substance okay so basically
we're alkalizing this hydrochloric acid
that we don't want to do and that's
going to inhibit digestion so consume
your lemon water at least maybe a half
hour to an hour before you eat anything
I consume my lemon juice in the morning
when I'm fasting so there's no
possibility of mixing it with a food
mistake number two is you're just
drinking this straight lemon juice
just drinking it right out of the bottle
whatever as a shot and you're allowing
this
very very strong acid to
expose to your teeth okay I mean think
about the pH of lemon juice is a pH of
two to three that is similar to
hydrochloric acid and so if you were to
routinely do that and expose it to your
teeth it could potentially kind of break
down some of the enamel on your teeth so
what I do is I dilute this lemon juice
with water and I consume it with a straw
okay that way it avoids going on my
teeth all right mistake number three if
you have an ulcer or gastritis
which you'll know real quick because
it's going to burn when you consume it
it would be contraindicated you don't
want to take anything that's acidic if
you have this inflamed stomach or an
ulcer okay so that would be
one thing you would want to avoid but
you'll probably very quickly recognize
if you have these conditions because
when you consume it it just it'll burn
your stomach all right and last mistake
is that if you have alkalosis right if
you have alkalosis where
your blood is just
a little excessively alkaline I mean
it's already alkaline slightly alkaline
but if it's more alkaline
and that's a condition called alkalosis
and it can aggravate that pH and make it
worse so a lot of the conditions or
symptoms that occur when your body is
too alkaline will get worse how do you
know if you have alkalosis here are some
common symptoms lightheadedness
numbness and tingling in the extremities
like your fingertips or feet tetany like
a little twitching underneath the left
eyelid or it could be anywhere in the
body rapid shallow breathing okay like
kind of a version of hyperventilating
I mean think about when you
hyperventilate right you're getting too
much oxygen and you're creating a CO2
deficiency
and without that CO2 you can't create
the acid necessary to help balance the
pH people have this idea that oxygen is
the best thing in the world right CO2 is
a waste product but you need a balance
of both okay you don't want to just have
one or the other if you have too much
oxygen like even in oxygen therapy there
are pretty major side effects especially
if it's pure oxygen you can end up with
edema swelling pulmonary edema it can be
very dangerous because the CO2 is
necessary
to make the oxygen available to your
cells and your tissues but the point is
that when you see someone with alkalosis
they're two alkaline they're breathing
will be off and it will almost look like
they're hyperventilating and then the
last symptom for alkalosis would be like
heart palpitations that type of thing
now I've done another video on lemon
juice that gets millions of views okay
if you haven't checked that one out I
put it up right here